Mario jumped onto the video game scene over
forty years ago, but there is so much more to
learn about everyone's favorite plumber before you
head to the theaters for his next big adventure.
Everyone knows who Mario is, and that's
no accident. Nintendo has meticulously
created one of gaming's biggest franchises
going all the way back to their flagship
character's debut appearance in 1981's
"Donkey Kong" arcade game. This series
has a long and proud history as one of
the most consistent, entertaining, fun,
and fresh franchises in all of gaming that
constantly pushes the boundaries of the
genre. That's exactly why this newest film
adaptation is so highly anticipated by fans.
Beginning with 1983's "Mario Bros" arcade
game, Nintendo transitioned the franchise
into home entertainment systems in 1985
with the release of "Super Mario Bros"
on the NES. Players enjoyed controlling
both Mario and Luigi as they traversed
the Mushroom Kingdom in search of Princess
Peach. This core game loop continued into
later installments on home consoles and
handhelds before making the leap to 3D.
"It'sa me! Mario! Hello!"
As gaming technology advanced, so too did
the complexity of games being released on
each successive console. With the release
of 1996's "Super Mario 64," new features
continued to be added to make each Mario
adventure more interesting. The franchise
remains an essential piece of gaming
history. Only time will tell which
aspects of this prestige franchise
will show up in the upcoming movie.
Originally, Mario was supposed to jump
into the big screen on December 21,
2022. Sadly for fans hoping to spend
the holiday season with Luigi, Bowser,
and Princess Peach, that release date
was pushed back to 2023. Fortunately,
we won't have to wait much longer to see
Mario's adventures in the Mushroom Kingdom.
"The Super Mario Bros. Movie" has
a new release date of April 5,
2023. We're expecting the movie to make quite
a bit of cash during its box office run,
as it won't have any animated competition
trying to draw similar crowds. As for
Nintendo's homeland of Japan, the film will
open on April 28, just a few weeks later.
Universal and Illumination spared no
expense when it comes to casting "The
Super Mario Bros. Movie." Voicing Mario
is none other than Star-Lord himself,
Chris Pratt. Charlie Day of "It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia" joins him as Mario's brother,
Luigi. Anya Taylor-Joy of "The Queen's Gambit"
and "The Menu" plays Princess Peach. We can
also expect to hear the scarier-than-usual
tones of Jack Black as antagonist Bowser.
In supporting roles, Keegan-Michael Key portrays
Toad, Seth Rogen steps in as Donkey Kong,
and Fred Armisen is the voice of Cranky Kong. The
announcement also notes that Charles Martinet,
who's voiced Mario and other notable characters in
the video games since the '90s,
will have "surprise cameos."
"The Super Mario Bros. Movie" is the result
of two powerful forces coming together:
Nintendo and Illumination. And that
collaborative dynamic is represented in
the film's producers. On one side, you've
got Chris Meledandri, the producer behind
the "Despicable Me" and "Sing" franchises. On
the other side, you've got Shigeru Miyamoto,
the genius who created Mario as well
as characters like Donkey Kong, Link,
and Zelda. Together, they bring their animation
and video game knowledge to the big screen.
As for who's directing, "The Super Mario Bros.
Movie" recruited two figures who are quite adept
at handling animated projects. Aaron Horvath and
Michael Jelenic the filmmakers behind "Teen Titans
Go! To the Movies" helm the picture. They're
working from a script penned by Matthew Fogel,
who previously wrote "The LEGO Movie 2: The
Second Part" and "Minions: The Rise of Gru."
As you might expect, "The Super Mario Bros.
Movie" got the standard rating for family fare:
PG. It perfectly lines up with Illumination's
other offerings like "Despicable Me" and
"The Secret Life of Pets." According to the
Classification and Ratings Administration's
website, the movie has earned its PG
rating for "action and mild violence."
We expect the violence to be incredibly
mild. Anyone familiar with the games knows
Mario's propensity for dishing out pain only
extends to jumping on Goombas or occasionally
throwing fireballs at a Koopa Troopas.
Even the trailers show that the action
will be light-hearted and comical, as
depicted when Donkey Kong hilariously
slaps our favorite plumber around or
when a penguin army assaults Bowser
with snowballs and the Koopa Kamek returns
the favor by magically tossing them aside.
Mario is one of the most popular
video game characters in history,
and the "Super Mario Bros" franchise
has always been a fundamental part of
gaming culture as a result. Because of this
popularity, it should come as no surprise
that this isn't the first time Mario has
graced the silver screen since his debut
appearance in 1981. Nintendo has tried multiple
times to turn Mario into a multimedia character
beyond just video games, but they've never
been particularly successful in the past.
The first time Mario and friends
ever appeared in a feature film
was in a 1986 animated adventure
picture named "Super Mario Bros.:
The Great Mission to Rescue Princess Peach!"
Since Mario had already achieved significant
popularity in his home country of Japan,
producers saw an opportunity to make a cheap,
60-minute anime based around Mario and Luigi's
usual goal of rescuing Princess Peach from Bowser.
Another more infamous big screen adaptation
was in the 1993 live-action film,
"Super Mario Bros," starring Bob Hoskins
as Mario and John Leguizamo as Luigi. The
movie was a total flop, currently holding
an abysmal 29% rating on Rotten Tomatoes.
"See ya' later, alligator."
The people who made "The Super Mario Bros.
Movie" certainly know their Mario history,
as the film is filled with all sorts of Easter
eggs and throwbacks for fans. For example,
both the film's official trailer and
a character poster show our heroes
driving down the Rainbow Road, a thoroughfare
instantly recognizable to "Mario Kart" fans.
Peach can even be seen riding a motorcycle,
paying homage to her outfit design that goes
all the way back to "Mario Kart Wii." Expect
homages to plenty of other worlds as well,
from "Luigi's Mansion" to the
original "Super Mario Bros."
On top of that, it looks like our titular
plumber dons quite a few super suits throughout
his adventure. In a teaser for the film, we
witness Mario's showdown with Donkey Kong,
where he puts on a literal catsuit, turning him
into Cat Mario from "Super Mario 3D World." In
the trailer, we also see him soaring around in the
Tanooki Suit, which hails from "Super Mario Bros.
3." We also know that quite a few classic Mario
baddies appear in the movie, from the Hammer Bros.
and the sorcerer Kamek to Goombas, Bob-ombs,
Piranha Plants, Buzzy Beetles, and Shy Guys.
We also suspect that elements from Mario's big
space-bound adventures might come into play. Some
shots of upcoming Mario-themed McDonald's toys
revealed a Luma, an adorable star-like creature
from "Super Mario Galaxy." Of course, there are
even references to unique "Mario" properties in
the marketing. During the Super Bowl, fans
were treated to a "Mario Bros." promo that
acted as a commercial for Mario and Luigi's
plumbing service. In the mock advertisement,
we're treated to the same Mario rap that's also
the incredibly cheesy theme of "The Super Mario
Bros. Super Show!," a series that would open
each episode with that plumbing hip-hop beat.
Mario as a character has completely
transcended the video game franchise
that created him by becoming a true, bona
fide pop culture icon. Everyone's favorite
plumber is a universally recognized symbol
of Nintendo and gaming in general thanks to
his unique place as both a leading
character and a corporate mascot.
Mario is an essential part of Nintendo's
business strategy since the "Super Mario"
games make millions of dollars with each release,
but this character also has staying power with
everyone. According to Guinness World Records,
Mario is one of the biggest and most instantly
recognized video game characters ever made by a
huge margin. He was officially named the second
"Most Recognizable Video Game Character" in
2009, only getting beat out by Pac-Man by 1%.
According to a statement by Mario's creator,
Shigeru Miyamoto, during an official briefing,
his iconic character even has notable comparisons
to Disney's Mickey Mouse. Miyamoto said,
"I felt bad that Mickey Mouse, who
had been hugely popular among fans,
including myself, for 60 years at that
point, was even being compared to Mario,
who had just been around
for a few years back then."
As anyone with an internet
connection can tell you,
it can get pretty heated online when fans
discuss their obsessions over social media.
While you might think that the fanbase
for Nintendo's flagship franchise would
be on the friendlier side since the source
material is so colorful, you'd be surprised.
With the release of "The Super Mario
Bros." trailer, fans have gone on record
to voice their opinions both positive and
negative about the new footage. While the
consensus seems to lean towards fans
loving the character designs, humor,
and storytelling of the trailer they also
generally are unsold on Nintendo's choice of
leading man. As mentioned, Mario is voiced by
Chris Pratt who seems to be using his regular
voice to play the character, rather than
imitating Mario's iconic Italian accent.
This was noted by many fans on Twitter
who commented that the supporting cast
featuring Charlie Day, Ana Taylor-Joy, and Jack
Black will do the heavy lifting for this film.
"No pressure."
We're entering a golden age of video game
adaptations with slam dunks like "Sonic
the Hedgehog" and HBO's "The Last of Us"
proving that the curse of bad movies based
on games can be broken. That being said,
there's a reason people thought that curse
existed in the first place since so many
terrible adaptations have been made over
the years. "The Super Mario Bros Movie"
has the potential to be the next example
of a video game movie done right, but only if
the filmmakers learned from previous mistakes.
Video game movies have a reputation for being
cheap cash-ins of popular gaming franchises,
made hastily and with little regard
for their source material. One of the
worst examples of this has to
be the "Resident Evil" films,
which forsake everything good about Capcom's
survival horror series by presenting big,
over-the-top spectacles and not much more.
2002's "Resident Evil" has only a 35% rating
on Rotten Tomatoes, but each successive entry
gets even worse reviews across the board.
"Mortal Kombat" is another arcade-based
franchise that has suffered from lackluster
adaptations since the first movie
in 1995, despite enjoying a cult
following these days. With the star
power behind the upcoming Mario movie,
it's unlikely this adaptation will join
the pantheon of bad video game flicks.
Like with most major franchise films today,
there's potential for countless spinoffs if
"The Super Mario Bros. Movie" does well at
the box office. In a 2021 interview with Fast
Company, Nintendo's global president Shuntaro
Furukawa said that the powers-that-be have no
intention of rushing things unless they're
certain there's a market for it. He said,
"Animation, in general, is something that we
are looking into, and not just this franchise."
One of the big movies that could come
down the pipeline if "The Super Mario
Bros. Movie" is successful is a standalone film
dedicated to Donkey Kong, the beloved gorilla
character voiced by Seth Rogen in this upcoming
adaptation. According to Giant Freaking Robot,
the film is already in development at Illumination
but the details on its potential plot remain
thin. It's likely, however, that many of
the characters introduced in "The Super
Mario Bros. Movie" will make appearances
in this proposed Donkey Kong solo feature.
Another spinoff we can expect in years
to come is a "Luigi's Mansion" movie
based on the series of action-adventure
games. Luigi's voice actor, Charlie Day,
expressed interest in the project in an
interview with Comicbook.com, saying,
"Yeah, my son was just playing Luigi's
Mansion the other day on his Switch. Look,
I'm thrilled to get the opportunity, I grew up
playing Super Mario Brothers as did everyone I
know so, we'll see! It's like anything
else in life, I'll go if I'm invited!"